[Musique]
l'artothèque propose actuellement une
exposition intitulée secteur réciproque
réalisé par didier klein artistes
réunionnais une exposition qui rassemble
des éléments autobiographiques et de la
fiction mais aussi des métaphores de
l'utopie le tout avec beaucoup de poésie
cette exposition au secteur réciproque
nous parle déjà de territoires ddt
espace b lieu à la fois différents et
pourtant équivalents
qui me montre c'est le bout de l'artiste
pour les voyages et les grandes
traversées maritimes
il reprend en quelque sorte mais en sens
inverse l'exemple sur l'ancêtre ces
hollandais du xviie siècle qui ont bravé
les océans pour archos veille à l'île de
la réunion
didier kla un artiste multimédia qui
passent allègrement du dessin à la
photographie à la vidéographie mais
aussi à la sculpture avec son
installation intitulée armada omega
c'est une sculpture une installation
sculpture cinétique puisqu'elle est en
partie
en partie en mouvement
petit origami
sont utilisés comme des éléments en
discussion
et
la conception elle est intimement liée à
l'idée qui est très forte chez l'artiste
de cette antenne ont mes gags nous
avions eu une autre fois à saint paul et
donc c'est aussi une métaphore de l'île
puisque tous les bateaux tous convergent
vers l'île ont convergé et que tu poses
convergeront encore
l'artiste réalise un travail
photographique et vidéographiques très
imbriqués l'un dans l'autre il
photographie comme un vidéaste et
réaliste et vidéo comme un photographe
il a choisi dans cette salle de vidéo ou
des plombs m'en fiche
le noir et blanc comme les caméras de
surveillance
à sa mémoire
bah
e
ce sont des vidéos très content de 3
minutes et il ne se passe absolument
rien on n'apprend rien ne se passait
rien c'était véritablement un moment en
suspens du
l'exposition secteur réciproque sera
visible à l'artothèque jusqu'au 15 mars
[Musique]